good afternoon so as we move out of
winter and into warm months can anyone
tell me what kind of viruses are gonna
be prevalent during the warm months as
opposed to the winter
well let's what did we have in the
winter what kind of virus is flu
anything else sorry Rhino virus is okay
what about what's gonna come up in the
summer months
remember polio of course we don't have
it anymore but if we did if we did here
that would be time for polio right
anything else I don't think I told you
anything else West Nile because the
mosquitoes are coming that's right
Eddie mosquito-borne viral disease will
become more prevalent in this summer we
don't have a lot in the US but there are
a number of Flavie viruses and other
vector borne viruses anybody seen the
press lately he's been reporting about a
mosquito-borne virus that was supposedly
sexually transmitted anybody seen this
no guys don't don't you look at the news
every major news online has got this
virus transmitted by sexual activity
supposed to be a mosquito-borne virus no
okay well this was a kind of exotic
virus from Africa which is
mosquito-borne and this could this I
think the guy was working there and he
came home and I think his wife was home
and then he developed symptoms and then
she did and they both got infected and
the idea is that it was transmitted
sexually so there's a study a clinical
study of two all right and so every
newspaper I've looked at has sexually
transmitted virus in the headlines so
it's really amazing this is what I'm
trying to correct by teaching this
course so if any of you become
journalists you have to read the paper
because in this case
you read the paper it says we cannot
prove that transmission was sexual but
the conditions suggest that it might be
but every journalist just takes the
headline and says sexually transmitted
infection so this really bothers me
because they don't read the papers they
don't have time I understand but now the
whole country is thinking that this
virus is sexually transmitted all right
so let's screw it up all right now that
I'm finished ranting about that let's
talk about vaccines anybody here been
immunized against the virus infection
you haven't been yes you have is anyone
not been immunized yeah that's more
likely so you're in the age group that
you are all immunized and vaccines are
what we're going to talk about today
because that's vaccination is a form of
immunization and as you know as we've
talked about throughout this course
there are lots of viruses impinging on
this all the time and they're always one
step ahead of us so is it possible that
we can get ahead of them can we get the
upper hand
can we do something to supplant
supplement our natural defenses indeed
could we even eradicate a virus from the
planet has any virus been eradicated do
you know yes it's the only one that's
been eradicated and we're working on
polio so today we'll talk about vaccines
and then next time we'll talk about
antivirals these are our two ways that
we try and intervene in the virus host
interaction and a population scale
vaccines and drugs can be really
effective but as you are beginning to
understand from this course the virus
host interaction is pretty complicated
and sometimes you can't intervene
without affecting things in unknown ways
and in fact even though we have an
entire course on viral adji what we
don't know is humbling when we test
vaccines we end drugs we find out how
little in fact we know vaccines that
work in the lab fail in the field
resistant mutants arise drugs have
unexpected side effects which you don't
find in small animal studies or small
human studies people refused
take their medicines is a big problem
where societies can't pay or won't use
good medicines so these last two are non
scientific issues you can have the best
vaccines or antivirals but if people
won't take them or pay for them they're
not going to ever be effective so both
vaccines and antiviral drugs have a
common principle and that is first any
way to block virus replication always
imposes selections for viruses that
bypass the block this is without
exception if you impinge in some way on
viruses replication that they will
evolve to get around that you will have
resistant mutants the vaccine escape
mutants and even selection for increased
virulence sometimes and we'll talk about
examples of all these as you know
viruses are obligate intracellular
parasites to inhibit viral replication
always carries inherent risks for the
hosts and these are the so called
side-effects of mainly antiviral therapy
which we will talk about next time
nevertheless despite all these problems
vaccines are our best defense against
viruses as you can see by this life
expectancy graph from about 1900 to the
present virus vaccines as well as
antibiotics and other health measures
healthcare measures have increased our
life expectancy amazingly look at this
from 50 years or less in 1902 now the
females get the longer life expectancy
80 years old if you're born in 2010 and
you are a female you should live to be
about 80 years or so of age does anyone
know what this decrease was in 1918 yeah
this is the effect of the pandemic of
influenza in 1918 1919 it decrease in
the life expectancy and so this is a
consequence of vaccines and many other
medicines it's really striking and I
don't know how one can argue and many
people do that
the vaccines have not been useful when
you have results such as these
vaccinations of course engages the
immune response that you already have to
prevent virus infections and it also
engages memory system as we will see the
key concept in using vaccines is that we
break the transmission cycle of
host-to-host spread so a virus has to go
from host the host to maintain itself in
a population and by immunizing with
vaccines we break this chain of
transmission and they do so by
stimulating a protective immune response
by mimicking an infection and providing
memories so here is again I think we've
seen this before a typical immune
response we're looking on the y-axis at
antibody or t-cells that are produced
the the adaptive immune response and
then we have our first infection and
starting at about seven days we have the
initial response can be antibodies or
cells which matures in about two weeks
and then declines with time so you don't
have the effector cells present at high
levels in the blood for long periods
they're there at low levels and they
persist for a long time and during that
time you have protective immunity when
you are challenged again with the
pathogen you have stimulation of
immunological memory so the memory
remains from the initial infection you
have a very rapid much more rapid than
the initial response as you can see and
more robust response so this is what
protects you this is immunological
memory and vaccines attempt to duplicate
this but of course they are not always
perfect at doing so and that's what
we'll talk about today the concept that
vaccines stimulate immune memory comes
from a lot of experimental findings one
of the earliest is an experiment where
an observation I should say done in the
Faroe Islands which are just north of
the United Kingdom which were for many
years remote and isolated because there
were no airplanes to get there they were
just boats so for example in 1781 there
was an outbreak of measles on these
islands and this is documented
and the health records for the next 65
years the island was free of measles
presumably because everyone was
immunized and there was no more virus
brought to the island there was an
outbreak in 1846 presumably ship docked
at the island and someone brought in
measles virus yet in that outbreak none
of those who survived the 1781 epidemic
as many years for this era but some did
none of those individuals were infected
they had immune memory so this was the
first demonstration of immune memory a
natural experiment demonstrating immune
memory it lasts a long time and should
be maintained without reexpose to virus
there are a number of immunologists who
believe that we always have challenges
to our immune system that stimulate the
longevity of memory but I don't know I
don't think there's good evidence for
that I think you don't need to have any
pathogen present the immune memory lasts
on its own so again vaccines attempt to
do this what is immune memory it's
essentially special kinds of T and B
lymphocytes memory cells that remain
after the infection is over and as we've
seen in the graph these have a enhanced
ability to proliferate rapidly and to
great extents after infection and the
concept of vaccines is that they
establish this memory without making you
sick without the pathogenic effects that
are typically seen when you have your
first encounter with any virus all right
so you have to design a vaccine so it
doesn't make you sick yet it protects
you and elicits memory and memory is the
main component of a vaccine because
you're usually not challenged with the
pathogen until sometime after you are
immunized so we're depending on memory
for protection nowadays in in developed
countries vaccines are an integral part
of our existence we immunize children we
Amin eyes adults of all ages even
animals we immunize many of our domestic
of course our pets our dogs and our cats
and we immunize farm animals as well and
as a consequence
any childhood diseases are rare when I
was growing up we used to always get
measles and mumps and rubella and that's
absent we don't get that any longer
this has radical changes in societies
and populations by doing this in
preventing disease you can make
societies more productive and more
easily learning for example so these are
a major part of the first world's public
health measures now but not the third
world yet and we strive to do that but
it hasn't yet happened so let's look at
a little history of vaccinations the
first the first credit for the vaccine
of course is given to Edward Jenner who
developed a vaccine against smallpox in
1917 96 and Jenner noticed that milk
maids who milk the cows and got cow pox
lesions on their hands usually didn't
get smallpox so he thought maybe cow pox
and smallpox are related and so he
actually took a cow pox lesion and
rubbed it into his skin of a young boy
and that boy was then protected against
smallpox the smallpox vaccine was then
developed and it was used for many many
years it's delivered by scraping the
virus into the outer layers of your skin
using this bifurcated needle it holds a
little drop of fluid with virus in it
like vaccine virus you scrape it into
the outer layers it multiplies very well
there and gives you immunity and this is
the vaccine that was used to eradicate
smallpox it's a very low-tech delivery
it can be delivered by untrained health
personnel and it was very easy to use
now this whole this is this whole
immunization approach was actually used
many many years before there are
historical records which showed for
example you know older Chinese societies
used what was called scarification to
try and prevent smallpox they would take
a pustule from a small potted person
grind it up and scrape it into someone
else's skin
that of course is problematic because
they're using wild type virus and so a
lot of the people would die but a number
would be protected and that was felt to
be worthwhile in fact in the u.s. during
the Revolutionary period smoke Dewar
epidemics of smallpox and many
individuals took their chances at being
scarify but with wild type virus because
that was 20 years before Jenner's
vaccine rather than have take a chance
on the virus killing you because it can
be lethal the next vaccine was developed
by Louis Pasteur in 1885 the rabies
vaccine and he introduced the team the
term vaccination into the literature and
it comes from cow the Latin word for cow
vodka in honor of Jenner who used cow
pox as the first vaccine and then we
didn't have many vaccines until the
1930s when we then developed yellow
fever and influenza virus vaccine so
there's some big gaps here in the early
years the use of of large-scale
vaccination campaigns can be helpful can
be very successful this is an example of
two here on the top is a polio
large-scale vaccination campaign in the
US so polio rose in incidents in the
u.s. from the 40s to the 50s where it
peaked at about their twenty to thirty
thousand cases per year in 1954 the
inactivated vaccine was developed and
introduced and as you can see they had a
dramatic impact on the incidence of
polio we then introduced an oral vaccine
in 1961 and now polio has been
eradicated from the US same with measles
here the incidence of measles for a
hundred thousand population here on the
y-axis the vaccine introduced in the
1960s dramatically impaired the spread
of measles in the US as well as that
late sequelae subacute sclerosing pan
encephalitis which happens many years
after the initial measles these are the
number of ssp cases in the u.s. reported
so in the peak 50 to 60 cases invariably
fatal and all of those were eliminated
as well I shouldn't say all of them
because we still have some measles in
the u.s. because there are individuals
who do not immunize their children
because they believe vaccines are
harmful or something else and so we have
pockets of susceptible individuals this
this often happens in groups in
communities so you have a lot of
susceptible children and there are
outbreaks because there's a lot of
measles virus easily and it can be
readily introduced into these
communities so here are two important
ideas about how vaccines do and don't
work first of all there's the concept of
herd immunity which is often
misinterpreted it means that you
immunize enough people to block virus
spread you don't immunize everyone you
immunize a fraction for whatever reason
and those who don't get the vaccine are
still protected not necessarily because
they get infected by the virus spreading
through the population but just because
you immunize enough people to stop the
spread of virus so there has to be a
critical number of susceptibles and if
you get that you can stop virus spread
not everyone has to be immune to protect
the population in fact that's good
because we can never immunize a hundred
percent especially here in the u.s. you
have to also maintain a critical level
of immunity in those individuals who do
get immunized and if the immunity falls
below a critical level you will get
epidemics even if you have a very good
vaccine so you have to have enough
people with sufficient immunity to block
transmission in a population this enough
people is complicated it differs
according to the virus the population
that we're talking about the even the
environment economics the healthcare
infrastructure social issues belief all
of these can impinge upon what is enough
people to stop transmission of a virus
but basically herd immunity says that
when virus spread will stop when the
probability of infection drops below a
critical threshold and that again is
virus and population specific for small
pox you need to have 80 to 85 percent of
the population to have sufficient
immunity enough immunity
in order to prevent spread so you don't
have to immunize everyone for measles
it's higher you have to have 93 to 95
percent of the population immunized to
stop virus spread now the problem is
that no vaccine is a hundred percent
effective so even if you could immunize
a hundred percent of the population you
wouldn't get a hundred percent immunity
and the number varies but it's rarely
over 90 percent for example the flu
vaccine is well below 90 percent in its
efficacy even if you if you immunize a
hundred people only 70 to 80 will
actually be protected depending on the
year and the vaccine so for example with
the measles vaccine when you immunize
80% of the population only 70 / 76
percent are actually immune which is not
bad it's a pretty good vaccine it's
better than the influenza vaccine all
right so these are just two examples
smallpox and measles every vaccine has
its own number and a big problem of
course is public complacency - any
vaccine program and here's some phrases
that we hear all the time for people not
getting immunized so why didn't you get
the flu vaccine this year why didn't I
get it it's not on the list I don't have
time this year actually I never get flu
is that on the list yes here it is
number three but I'm right because I
worked on it and I got infected with
every possible strain there you should
say you're wrong because you can't
because it varies infinitely and I can't
have possibly done that viral diseases
are a thing of the past
kids should get infected naturally
there's a good one I've heard that many
times I'm not injecting anything into my
body and all the things that vaccines do
that make you sick because autism MS
here you go right this is a very popular
one I know a guy who got the flu shot
and then got the flu well of course it
takes about two to three weeks to get
your immunity kicked in right so you
could get the flu right after getting
the flu shot but if you got an
inactivated flu
vaccine you wouldn't be getting the flu
from it but that's what some people feel
anyway when these attitudes prevail then
we have a problem with large-scale
programs and right now we have a problem
because the anti vaccine sentiment in
this country is quite strong and growing
and it's all based on misinformation and
it's really unfortunate because people
are not getting information from
scientists cuz they don't trust us in
part but they get information from
journalists and lawyers and other
individuals who really don't know with
the science behind immunization that
there's nothing dangerous about vaccines
that there's nothing bad to put into
your body etc etc so this is a really
big problem and a lot of our childhood
infections measles mumps are coming back
because of this complacency it's not
just a complacency it's an active
opposition against immunization and
there are many variables that influence
how immunization proceeds very very
complicated variables poverty social
structure infrastructure and politics
all of these even in the richest
countries in the world affect public
health in developing countries they're
often simply out of the question people
can't even find clean water to drink on
a daily basis so a vaccine is a luxury
and you need money to do these
large-scale programs the large-scale
polio eradication program costs billions
of dollars and fortunately Bill Gates is
providing a large amount of that to
proceed and of course right now our
economy is bad so these are never
popular in those cases and then there
are people who just don't like the large
social programs that I have to tell you
who they are but they don't like
immunization programs which is silly it
has nothing to do with your philosophy
about social programs it's about keeping
people healthy and as I've said the
Gates Foundation has taken a major lead
they've provided money not only for
polio but also for providing hepatitis B
vaccine and this is great we need more
people that were willing to do this and
take the money they've made from society
and invested into making health care my
philosophy is that if we
develop something that prolongs people's
lives like a vaccine everyone should be
able to benefit from it it shouldn't be
restricted by the cost for example okay
let's talk about how to make a vaccine
did I just skip yes okay how to make a
vaccine so you have to make a good
immune response as we have said and
sometimes you have to make calculations
so for example the th1 and th2 response
and many infections has to be properly
balanced and we talked a little bit
about that vaccines have to mimic that
the gold standard is that a vaccinated
individual has to be protected against
the pathogen that causes disease making
antibodies is not enough you can't just
inject a vaccine into people and say it
makes antibodies that's fine you have to
show that the vaccine induces protection
so that requires a complicated clinical
trial vaccines can be active or passive
and active vaccine is that you put the
pathogen or material derived from it
into the recipient and this gives you
long term protection so these are most
of the vaccines we're going to talk
about today a passive vaccine you put
the products of the immune response into
the person you put antibodies or immune
cells that you get from another
individual this gives you short-term
protection but sometimes you don't have
any choice in the a good example is
rabies there's a product called rabies
immune globulin which is basically
antibodies against a rabies virus it
used to be pooled human serum from
people who had had rabies and it was
purified so as not to be pathogenic and
if someone is bitten by a rabid animal
you give them this initially to help
delay the spread of the virus and here's
here's a product sheet from one of these
more recent one rabies immune globulin
so this is these are some of the u.s.
brand names here it's given along with
the vaccine to prevent infection caused
by rabies virus
and this gives you protection until you
your antibodies can kick in so if you
get bitten by a dog for example and
there's suspected rabies the immune
globulin is injected at the bite site to
help neutralize the virus and then you
get immunized as well on top of it so
now there are monoclonal antibodies that
are produced humanized monoclonal
antibodies that are produced so we don't
have to use human sierra a passive
vaccine occurs when you are born you get
antibodies from your mother so here is a
course of development from conception
through birth and adult years this is
the fraction of adult antibody levels of
different kinds IgM IgG and IgA and
initially you receive antibodies from
from your mother as you can see here
this is passively transferred maternal
IgG and they they of course peak at
birth you can't get any more from your
mom after you're born but then you they
slowly decline in the child's blood by
nine months they're gone and then they
are replaced by your own IgM IgG and IgA
so as you become an assaulted with
various pathogens you develop your own
immune response so you can't make one in
utero so your mother provides you with
some protection and you depend on your
mother's experience for this the more
infections she has had the more
antibodies you will get so that's a
natural passive antibody one of the
requirements for a good vaccine has to
be safe of course you can't cause
disease or can't have side effects that
have don't have anything to do with the
disease they have to induce protective
immunity in the population and as I said
not everybody needs to be immunized
again yes
no no they don't receive memory cells
just antibodies from the mom and then
those declined eventually and you make
your own memory cells as you have
infection experiences as I said herd
immunity is important so your vaccine
has to induce herd immunity the
protection has to be long-lasting and
this is not assumed you can't assume
that any vaccine you made is gonna be
long-lasting some lasts forever in some
lasts a few years and the key is to
optimize the vaccine to make it as
long-lasting as possible it also should
be cheap w-h-o says the ideal vaccine
for its purposes is less than one dollar
a dose which is a challenge but it has
been done polio the polio vaccine being
used for eradication costs about five
cents a dose so you can get it quite
cheap when you make a lot has to be
genetically stable we'll talk about that
storage would be great if you didn't
have to refrigerate or freeze your
vaccines many of them do require
freezing right now but a whole new
generation of vaccines are being
developed that don't have to be frozen
they're really amazing stabilization
agents that are being used and how it's
delivered is really important and
traditionally all our vaccines have been
injected we now have more that can be
taken orally but that's not appropriate
for every pathogen but again this is
changing too I've read recently about a
kind of patch that you would put on your
skin it's impregnated with vaccine and
the patch has tiny tiny knot needles but
tiny protuberances in it that pushed the
vaccine into your skin you just wear it
for a few days and you get immunized you
don't need a physician to do that you
can just put it on your skin yourself so
these are the vaccines in the future so
let's talk about some of the ways we
make vaccines today they're all shown
here starting with a parental virus
we'll talk about a couple of these the
the we can attenuate its virulence to
make eight what we call a live natural
virus vaccine now we we use the term
live vaccines even though
we know that viruses are not living
because it's been ensconced in the
literature and rather than changing
every slide
I got live on here but what I mean is
infectious not live so we have
infectious attenuated vaccines we have
inactivated virus vaccines we have
subunit vaccines where we take the
original virus and break it up and then
we have a whole generation based on
recombinant DNA approaches we can clone
the genes for individual viral proteins
or the entire genome we can clone
antigens in entire viral genomes live
virus vectored vaccines we can make DNA
vaccines where we inject DNA into
individuals and this is also being
tested in many ways and then we can have
vaccines where you express individual
viral proteins and sometimes they
assembled to form virus particles and
these are cold virus like particle
vaccines we've talked about some of
these before or you can just simply take
individual proteins and make subunit
vaccines so these are the current types
of approaches that are being used but
many more are being developed and will
be present in the future so this is a
list of almost all of the vaccines that
are currently available just to give you
an idea of the range there are quite a
few but by no means is every virus
included in this list for example we
have adenovirus vaccines which are just
used for the military because they're
particularly susceptible enclosed
conditions to having rampant respiratory
infections hepatitis A and B vaccines in
fact anyone know what's gone on recently
with respect to hepatitis B vaccine now
well the fellow who discovered the virus
just died licensed by route Bloomberg
right so he was the guy who in fact he
graduated from Columbia in 1951 before
us and then he he discovered the virus
and received a Nobel Prize for it a
couple of influenza vaccines most
inactivated and attenuated and then we
have measles mumps and rubella vaccines
which are all combined together the
papillomavirus vaccines
here rabies smallpox varicella two
different varicella vaccine yellow fever
so there you go that's the the panoply
and these are just the kinds of vaccines
and when they are given the vaccination
schedule so you know some of the anti
vaccine people say Oh kids get dozens
and dozens of vaccines there's too many
antigens it's not healthy well there's
not dozens of dozens of vaccines you
know these are not all childhood
vaccines so it's again more
misinformation because people don't
check their facts and they hear Oh
dozens yeah that sounds about right I'm
not gonna have my kid immunized so let's
talk about inactivated vaccines first
these are simply viruses that you
propagate normally and then you
inactivate their infectivity in a
chemical way you can use formalin
detergents other chemicals they're not
infectious
but the antigenicity is still there they
will if injected make antibodies that
protect you and that give you a memory
response and the first one we'll talk
about is a polio inactivated vaccine
polio of course is the virus that causes
polio myelitis the word polio myelitis
comes from the greek for polio and itis
which is inflammation in Latin and in a
1959 textbook of medicine it was called
a common acute viral disease
characterized by brief febrile illness
sore throat headache and vomiting
stiffness of neck and back and many of
those you can recognize as nonspecific
symptoms caused by cytokine production
in many cases a lower neuron paralysis
develops in the early days of illness so
of course today it's no longer common
it's not in the medical textbooks
anymore this is what polio used to do in
the US he used to put many individuals
in iron lungs because often the virus
would paralyze the breathing muscles and
so the only way was to put an individual
in a machine that would breathe for them
many of these individuals eventually got
out after therapy and they were able to
breathe again but US hospitals were
often full of these and now there aren't
any left of course and one of our
presidents FDR of course had polio as
well
because of that he initiated fundraising
that eventually led to the development
of both polio vaccines the March of
Dimes
so the inactivated vaccine is polio
virus that is treated with formalin and
that destroys the infectivity of the
virus this vaccine was first tested in
1954 it was developed by Jonas Salk and
this I find an amazing clinical trial
was tested in 1 million eight hundred
thousand children half got the vaccine
and half got the placebo and it gave 50%
protection which at the time was great
because everyone was scared to death of
polio and then it was licensed right
away and and began to be used
unfortunately what happened next was an
interesting commentary on on
immunization well first of all let's
look at the headlines that resulted this
is amazing these are all the newspapers
in New York that used to exist back in
1954 and I think most there are Muslim
are gone except to the Times in the post
but these are amazing headlines and this
gives you an idea of how serious polio
was in the u.s. at this time
unfortunately after releasing the the
vaccine within ten days a lot of the
recipients developed polio eventually
there were 216 vaccine associated cases
in 94 children and a hundred and
sixty-six contacts and there were a
number of deaths as well so you can
imagine your parents bring you to be
immunized because they're so scared of
polio and then you get polio and you die
the reason was one of the laboratories
that made the vaccine Qatar labs didn't
do it the inactivation properly and
there was live virus or infectious virus
in the preparations and so Qatar
labyrinth this was actually the first
vaccine related lawsuits that preceded
they were very publicized and Paul Offit
who is a pediatrician at Penn thinks
this was the beginning of the anti
vaccine sentiment in the US the public
had this huge trust in polio vaccine and
the first polio of
released cost polio so there were lots
of lawsuits over this and we're still
probably paying for it till this day and
nevertheless the issue was resolved this
with its use was resumed and from 1955
to 1960 polio fell to about 2,500 cases
in the US and if you're interested in
this whole incident where the
inactivated vaccine actually caused
paralysis Paul Offit wrote a very good
book the cutter incident where he told
about how this happened yes yeah it's a
tough problem right it was a little bit
of slyness on the part of the public
health authorities it was never admitted
that there was a problem publicly so
they did a lot of covering up and hiding
it's all in this book and there was a
period of a few months where the
immunization rates were very low but
then they resumed again yeah yes yes it
talks about what they did wrong it talks
about the lawsuits and all the
precedents that were set by this is
really good and Paul Offit is a
pediatrician but he also has developed
he developed one of the rotavirus
vaccines that we've talked about also
he's a very strong vaccine proponent
he's very good at explaining this yes
well that's a very good question so
initially you do epidemiology and you
say the kids that got paralyzed were
they immunized and right away you could
look at the immunization records and
tell that then you say what batch of
vaccine did they get so the vaccine was
made by six or seven different
manufacturers so they could trace it
back to one or two manufacturers and
then they looked in those Lots and they
found infectious virus so that that's
basically the chain of events that
occurred so these this vaccine the
inactivated vaccine works it's injected
this is an intramuscular injection and
you get antibodies developing in your
blood and so then if you are challenged
with polio which it comes in your mouth
and goes to your intestinal tract the
virus replicates in the mucosal surfaces
it gets into the blood and then at that
point it will encounter the antibodies
that have been induced by immunization
and it will be neutralized so this
vaccine prevents the virus from
spreading any further although it
doesn't prevent it from replicating in
your intestine so if you're immunized
with IPV you could still replicate polio
and shed it and spread it okay so that
that is the sorry the inactivated
vaccine and again introduced 1955 and
brought polio down significantly in the
US the other inactivated vaccine I want
to talk about is the influenza vaccine
influenza viruses are very different of
course there are below viruses with
glycoproteins in the envelope there are
three types of influenza A B and C and
there antigenically distinct so you have
to immunize against each one if you want
to protect against each one a and B are
the two that we immunize against they
cause the most serious disease C doesn't
cause significant enough disease to
require a vaccine the inactivated
influenza vaccine why do we have it well
because you get about 50,000 deaths per
year in the u.s. due to influenza it's a
lot of people dying and it really is is
surprising when people say you know flu
is not a serious disease I don't need to
be immunized well it's pretty serious
for those 50,000
people who died and how do you know
you're not going to be one of them so I
think that's it that's one reason to be
immunized so the vaccine is produced in
chicken eggs
the virus is inoculated into the vaccine
it grows in the egg and then they take
out the virus and inactivate it with
formalin and detergent disrupt it and
then this is immunized this is injected
into you there's currently a vaccine
produced in cell culture which is being
used in the European Union so if you
have an egg allergy you shouldn't get
flu vaccine grown in eggs
but eventually this vaccine will come to
the US and then you can get that as well
we make almost a hundred million doses a
year last year I think we made over 150
million doses in 2009 that is when the
recent pandemic emerged so we make a lot
of flu doses it's 60 to 90 percent
effective in children and adults below
65 years of age so 60% is not terribly
effective 60 people out of a hundred
would be protected so it's not the best
vaccine this is pretty old technology
and we need to improve it over 65 it's
really really poor protection which
doesn't even last an entire flu season
if if you you're over 65 you get
immunized in September which is
typically when you start immunizing by
the next January or February that
immunity is probably waned sufficiently
that they could get influenza by then so
we need to do some improving here what
the vaccine does is makes antibodies
against the - glycoproteins that are in
the virus particle DHA or the na and
that is what protects you from infection
the problem with this vaccine is you
have to change it every year or two
because the viral envelope genes change
and therefore we have to select new
strains that we think are going to
circulate every year and that's done at
the beginning of the year and decisions
are made because they have to go into
production and even starting in January
or February getting a vaccine out by
August is not easy but that's what
happens and then you can start
immunizing people in September the way
this is
because most isolates that you get from
people most virus isolates don't grow
very well what you do is you pick your
strain and then you make a reassortant
with a strain that you know grows really
well in eggs and then you make sure that
the genes for the H a and the na come
from the clinical isolate that you want
to protect against and then the all the
other ones come from the high yielding
strain so this is done every year you
make a reassortant and then you get that
to grow really well in eggs so the
current vaccine is a trivalent
preparation it has three components it
has a 2009 h1n1 strain this is the
strain that emerged that year the
pandemic swine origin influenza strain
there is also another type a strain an
h3n2 these viruses continue to circulate
and then there's an influenza B string
all right yes no it's not terribly cheap
it's not less than $1 per dose you need
one egg per per dose so that's a 150
million eggs you need and the production
is it's complicated the inoculation of
the eggs and the harvesting and the
inactivation so I I think the cell
culture of vaccine would be cheaper but
there's an even cheaper alternative
coming up which will talk about subunit
vaccines you break the virus into
components and then you immunize with
purified components one one version you
can clone the gene for let's say H a of
flu each clone it you express it
somewhere bacteria yeast in sick cells
cell culture you have to decide what is
best that you purify the protein and use
that as an immunogen and typically the
antigen is a capsid protein or a
membrane protein which you know will
provide protection antibodies against it
will provide protection subunit vaccines
have some advantages there are no viral
genomes that can replicate it's just a
purified protein there's no possibility
of contamination with infectious virus
or foreign proteins I shouldn't really
say there is no good because whenever
you produce something in a cell there's
always a possibility of
contaminating it depending on how you
purify it but it's less likely to be
contaminated than a virus that you grow
in cells some disadvantages these are
expensive because the purification is
costly
typically the antigenicity is low it's
just a single protein and usually the
virus itself makes a great antibody
response but when you start breaking it
into proteins not as good these
typically make good antibodies but not
t-cells which you may need depending on
the virus and the delivery system isn't
great most of these have to be injected
and as I say we're trying to get away
from that they all have one problem is
that the proteins don't replicate of
course they're not viruses they don't
infect cells they don't send out a
danger signal remember how we talked
about how viruses interact with the
innate immune system the dendritic cells
sense the infection and they go on to
tell the t-cells something is going on
well protein antigens don't do that very
well because they don't replicate and a
good example of this is a vaccine
against respiratory syncytial virus
which was produced in the early 60s it
was a failure because it didn't induce a
good danger signal we'll talk about that
in a moment when you use a pure protein
as an image and you often require an
adjuvant and what this does is to
stimulate inflammation remember
inflammation the production of cytokines
that amplify the adaptive response a
pure protein engine is often not good at
doing this so we put adjuvant CIN to
make better inflammation and before we
talk about adjuvant so let me tell you a
little bit about this respiratory
syncytial virus vaccine this was
published in the in 2008
lack of antibody affinity maturation due
to poor toll-like receptor stimulation
leads to enhanced respiratory syncytial
virus disease so in a natural infection
with respiratory syncytial virus the
virus binds to toll-like receptors on
the cell surface and these are the
sensors of the innate immune system the
toll-like receptors say ah there's a
foreign virus here they signal the
innate immune system in addition when
the virus gets into cells it makes
double-stranded RNA which is also sensed
and all of these things make it really
strong and eight response and
consequently a great adaptive response
which means really good antibody
affinity maturation high affinity
antibodies so the innate responses is
crucial for getting really good
antibodies when they made the vaccine
they inactivated with formalin and they
didn't know this at the time but it
turned out to be a really poor ligand
for the toll-like receptors it no longer
stimulated toll-like receptors so you've
got very poor innate responses to this
vaccine and you got very low affinity
antibodies produced so just because the
innate response wasn't stimulated you've
got really bad antibodies these bound
the virus but they didn't neutralize it
and in fact they led to uptake of the
virus into FC receptor bearing cells
very much like dengue and more severe
disease okay so now we know that the
problem is toll-like receptor
stimulating and we can make a vaccine
that better does that all right what are
adjuvant these are substances that
stimulate early processes and in
recognition particularly inflammation
they make better inflammation right all
those signals of inflammation the
cytokines released they help make better
antibody responses they help make a more
they also help produce a more robust
response with less antigen so sometimes
with an adjuvant you can use less
antigen which may be good in some cases
there are at least three ways that we
know that they work we're always
developing new ones they sometimes
present antigens as particles depending
on the adjuvant they localize the
antigen to the site of inoculation for a
longer period so they can stimulate
inflammation better and also they have
direct stimulation of the innate
response by improving overall
inflammation in the u.s. we use two
different kinds of adjuvant Cinar
vaccines we use aluminum salts in the
hepatitis B virus vaccine and Aleut and
a so4 in one of the human papillomavirus
vaccine this is aluminum hydroxide and
mono phosphoryl lipid a so it's a
mixture of two different things we don't
use edge of
in any other vaccines in Europe some
influenza vaccines have a German sin
them some successful subunit vaccine as
well the hepatitis B vaccine is a good
subunit vaccine this consists nowadays
of the capsid protein produced in yeast
so the gene for the protein was cloned
inserted into yeast it's expressed the
protein assembles into empty particles
and no adjuvant is needed for this
because it's the particle even though
it's just one protein it makes a
particle which is a natural adjuvant you
don't need to add anything to this
vaccine here is the hepatitis B virus
particle and the particles that are made
when you just express the capsid protein
are shown here two different kinds so of
course you don't have the genome the
viral DNA and so forth or the membrane
but you make these particles which are
quite immuno genic so that's a very good
vaccine the human papillomavirus
vaccines there are two of them now
Gardasil made by merck which is against
four serotypes produced in yeast so you
express a single capsid protein of the
virus here's the variant up here the
major capsid protein is called l1 you
take the gene encoding it you make it
you express it either in yeast or in
insect cells which is what
GlaxoSmithKline does to make its version
Cervarix it's made in insect cells you
then express that you get virus-like
particles you purify them and then you
can immunize individuals these are
injected vaccines the Cervarix is given
with an adjuvant the Gardasil is not and
so these are anti-cancer vaccines they
protect you against different kinds of
cancer induced by these human papilloma
viruses and we recently had a twit with
Michele Osborne who works on papilloma
viruses and if you're interested in
hearing more from her she said listen to
that let's move on to live in quotes
attenuated vaccines these are vaccines
where viral replication occurs and
stimulates an immune response
sometimes the virions are contained to
the site of replication
infection typically induces a mild
disease or none here is what if live
virus vaccine does compared to a killed
virus vaccine so when you inject your
first dose of killed virus vaccine you
have an immune response it wanes
you then give a second or a third
booster to get substantial responses but
and an infectious virus vaccine
amplifies itself you give one dose the
virus replicates and you get substantial
immune responses without multiple
injections how do you make such viruses
how do you take a virus which causes
disease and people and then derive one
that doesn't cause disease we still
haven't been able to do this in a
directed fashion in other words we still
can't say let's make a mutation in this
gene it will cause the virus not to be
pathogenic most of our vaccines are made
empirically
you take a virus and you'd grow it in
certain conditions and hope that at some
point you lose virulence of the virus so
here's an example you take a pathogenic
virus from a patient you grow it in
cultured cells and you may grow it in
another kind of cell and as you grow it
in cell to cell the virus acquires
mutations say that make it grow better
and a monkey cells compared to a human
cell and now when you infect people it
doesn't grow well and it may be a
candidate for a vaccine so this is a
crude approximation of the strategy it's
entirely empirical you have to just do a
hit-and-miss approach and hope for the
best
polio virus the polio virus infectious
vaccines are a great example of this
even though we had a killed virus
vaccine IPV and activated polio vaccine
many people felt that that would not
eliminate polio because it didn't mimic
a natural infection so a number of
individuals worked on attenuating
viruses to make an infectious vaccine in
1952 Hillary cope raske and John Enders
John Enders of course the first person
to show that you could grow polio and
cell culture showed that you could pass
the virus in cell culture and it would
lose virulence for animals it's a
strategy I just told you they actually
showed this in 1952 and so a number of
individuals worked on this Albert Sabin
his three strains of OPV were licensed
in the u.s. in 1961 and this is an
example of how he derived one of the
three serotypes this is the type three
component
he took the original polio isolate which
was from a fatal case of polio and look
what he did he passed it intracerebral
II in monkeys twenty-one times eight
times and monkey testicle cultures 39
times in monkey kidney cultures three
plaque purifications and at each step he
would take this virus and inject it into
monkeys and ask is it pathogenic and
eventually he got a virus that wasn't
and that became the vaccine strain oh
this of course is done in the 1950s
there's no molecular biology there's no
cloning there's no sequencing the only
thing he knew was when you injected into
a monkey it did not cause paralysis and
eventually these were put into people in
clinical trials and these were the polio
virus vaccines now in the 1980s when we
got the ability to sequence DNA and
other genomes we then could sequence
Sabin strains and ask how did they
differ from the viruses that he started
with and that's shown here in fact there
are very few changes in these vaccine
strains compared to the viruses that he
made them from in fact there are two of
the three serotypes there are only two
changes and if we were licensing this
vaccine today the FDA would look at this
and say not enough changes you can't
have this as a vaccine but back then we
didn't have sequencing so they were
licensed well all three of these
vaccines by the way have a change in the
5-prime non-coding region of the viral
RNA I don't know if you remember that
but that's an extensively folded region
that has an iris in an internal ribosome
entry site has a lot of stem loop
structures remember this is the polio
genome this is the coding region in the
middle has a five-prime non-coding
region it's extensively folded and these
mutations in three vaccine strains are
all in this 5 prime non-coding region in
particular in this
stem-loop section here number number V
and they're shown here the type 1 the
type 2 and the type 3 changes that
attenuate the virulence of poliovirus so
this virus is ingested this vaccine you
drink you'd get a little bit of liquid
in a capsule you drink it it goes to
your intestine it multiplies there you
get nice intestinal immunity that mimics
a real infection the virus also gets
into your blood where it makes
antibodies in memory there as well and
then you are protected from infection
and as OPV remember only protected your
blood from circulation of virus OPV does
both it blocks infection at the mucosal
surface and within the blood now the
inactivated vaccine was supplanted by
the oral vaccine in 1961 that led to the
elimination of polio in the US
unfortunately the vaccine though in 10
you ated vaccine can also cause polio
this is called vaccine associated polio
and it was recognized actually from its
very beginnings that when you feed
people these vaccine strains what they
excrete in their stools is more neuro
virulent than what you give them so you
can feed people polio vaccine you take
what they shed you put that into monkeys
and that's more neuro virulent than what
you started with and when when these
vaccines were first used in Eastern
Europe and the 60s they were paralytic
cases associated with immunizing
individuals with them and as we
eliminated polio from the US the last
case of wild polio in the US was 1979
after that the only polio in the US was
vaccine a Saudi Associated paralytic
polio or vapp and the rate was one per
one point four million doses of vaccine
distributed they were about seven to
eight such cases per year in the US and
that's why by 2000 we decided to switch
back to the inactivated vaccine because
the only polio was caused by the vaccine
itself which obviously was not
acceptable
and so this is a nice graph which shows
you the progress of polio eradication in
the u.s. these are this is the number of
paralytic cases here on the y-axis and
this is the year so we're starting in
1961 these bars are the vaccine
associated polio cases so the black bars
are that polio case is caused by the
vaccine the line is the total number of
polio in the US so you can see in the
early 60s there was a lot more wild
polio but then as we eliminated
indigenous polio here's the last case in
1979 20 cases in an Amish community in
Pennsylvania
then 1980 on on no more wild polio the
only polio was caused by the vaccine so
2000 we switched to the killed vaccine
now no more polio in the u.s. why does
the vaccine cause polio because when you
ingest it it replicates in your
intestine and it rapidly reverts so
those few mutations remember that Albert
Sabin selected for to make the virus
attenuated they rapidly revert as the
virus replicates in your gut and this
was first determined in 1985 by Phil
miner who was a virologist in the UK and
he and his wife had their first child
and at 2 months of age what happens they
get their first dose of oral polio
vaccine so Phil collected every diaper
that his child produced for the first
three months and he brought them into
the lab and he scraped off the feces and
isolated polio from it and sequenced it
and this he published this in nature so
this is his child David minor this is
the bulk of the paper and what happens
with David is that at 24 hours he this
is for the type 3 vaccine only we're
looking at 24 hours the vaccine is fine
it has a you at 472 at 31 hours it's
still fine but look at 35 hours now you
have a mixture of viruses with a UNSC
the C is the base that makes this virus
virulent at this position so within a
few days David minor was shedding fully
virulent polio virus if you inject this
virus into monkeys it paralyzes that
which is shown by these high numbers
here in subsequent studies this has been
shown to happen in every child that gets
oral polio vaccines all three strains
revert during multiplication in your
digestive tract so that's why some kids
get polio when they get the polio
vaccine because it's genetically
unstable amazingly most kids are fine
but one one per 1.4 million get
paralyzed I don't know why we don't
really understand why that occurs I
think they have a suboptimal innate
response and a genetic predisposition to
that but that's never been proven
alright there's another live infectious
vaccine I want to tell you about it's a
flu met flu vaccine it's called flu mist
this is a live attenuated trivalent
three strains nasally administer anybody
ever have flu mist here you have they
put a little thing and shoot it up your
nose and you're supposed to inhale right
and a lot of it drips out pulls on your
shirt but this is a nice way to do it if
you don't like needles this is also made
in eggs though so if you have egg
allergies you can't get it but it has an
interesting origin these are the three
strains that are in it it is also
reassortant of a master donor strain so
this master donor was developed by
passing virus at low temperature until
it replicated really well at low
temperature but not at higher
temperatures and then what you do is you
reassert the strain so that you have the
genes for the H a and na from whatever
your current strain is you make a
reassortant and these viruses are cold
adapted in temperature sensitive so they
prefer multiplying at a low temperature
which is your upper tract they don't go
into your lung because once they go
there the temperature is too high and
they don't replicate so that's why they
don't cause disease they stay up in the
upper tract and give you immunity so
they're cold adapted temperature
sensitive they replicate only your
nasopharyngitis oh these are limited in
their distribution because a lot of
doses are not made yet but eventually I
think more and more of this will be made
especially as we move
to the cell culture production this is
just to show you how these strains are
isolated it's it's complicated so you
start with a parental virus that is
whatever virus you want to immunize
against then you have this master donor
virus which is cold adapted and
temperature sensitive this was developed
at the University of Michigan in Ann
Arbor actually in the 60s so this is old
technology
these are reassortant and then you
select for viruses with the H a NN a of
your virus and and everything else from
this donor strain you go through a
number of egg passages and harvests and
eventually you you make a big bulk
process and you get your vaccine so it's
a complicated process which is why it's
not cheap now what about future vaccines
are for flu this is one that I really
like and this is one you can make in
plants so if you just express the H a of
influenza virus in cells the H a that
glycoprotein on the surface what you get
are particles made like this the H a is
enough to stimulate budding of a
membrane particle that has the H a
glycoprotein embedded in it so these are
virus-like particles and these are quite
immuno genic and they can protect you
against influenza this can also be done
in plants you can express the H a of flu
in a plant and this is very cheap when
you do this one square meter of plants
makes twenty thousand doses of vaccine
so this is like a square meter this
thing right here and they do this in
tobacco plants because tobacco plants
you can easily put genes into and there
so they're genetically manipulative
tobacco plants makes twenty thousand
doses of X at under twenty cents a dose
so this is significantly cheaper and my
colleague Dixon de palma is a big
proponent of making vertical farms and
cities growing your crops hydroponically
so we thought that this would be this is
Dixon here you'll meet him later in the
course and we think we should that he
should make these flu vaccines in his
vertical farms and it would be even
cheaper so here's an example of why it
would be really good to make this
vaccine in plan
so let's say you have a new pandemic
strain of influenza virus right here so
night in 2009 we had a new strain emerge
all right
so then you start making your egg-based
vaccine and it takes you about six
months to start putting egg-based
vaccine into the market you have to make
a reassortant with a high yielding egg
vaccine you have to produce it in eggs
and inactivate it you have to test it a
bit so you're six months in by then the
pandemic first wave is already beginning
here's the peak of disease and you've
missed it by the time you get your eggs
vaccine into the population and in fact
it turns out that for 2009 all the
vaccines that we released were really
too late to make an impact on h1n1
disease on the other hand if you make it
in plants you can immediately get the
sequence of the H a from your first
isolate and you can within three months
have a plant-based vaccine supply
because all you have to do is express it
in plants it's very easy to purify from
the particles from the plant fluids and
you could have an egg-based vaccines so
these are now in clinical trials and
people there a number of publications
already describing their immunogenicity
yeah I'm sure there will be that's why
they have to put it in many many people
before it will be licensed but in the
early phase one safety tests they're
they're nothing so far but we'll see
because it is an extract of tobacco
plant so you can imagine that there
might be something in it so all of the
vaccinations we've talked about leads to
one question can you have a decayed
viral diseases and as we said earlier
smallpox was eradicated in 1978 there's
no more smallpox it's the only major
human disease to be eradicated and what
do you need to eradicate a virus
infection well two main features one you
should have just one host that the virus
replicates in so small pox only
replicates in people polio only
replicates in people if it replicates in
animals then it's a very
difficult to eradicate it because even
if you get rid of the virus and people
that's still in the animals and you have
to induce lifelong immunity to
vaccinations so if you have these two
you can possibly eradicate so measles is
another candidate for eradication it
just replicates in people and
vaccination induces lifelong immunity
now this is a very interesting situation
we're in with smallpox since it's been
eradicated and there's almost no pox
there are just two more stocks of Vire
there are two stocks of virus left in
the world one in CDC in Atlanta and one
in Russia and so w-h-o has said for
years we should destroy all these virus
stocks because maybe the terrorists
would get a hold of them and use them
for nefarious purposes we don't get
immunized against smallpox anymore
because there's no disease but we're all
susceptible so it would be a good the
argument is that it would be a bioterror
weapon and they should be destroyed
whether or not is going to happen or not
I don't know it's been debated for 10
years and it's not clear what will
happen I have found views but I'll save
you from those anyway I wrote I put up a
poll some time ago on my blog should
smallpox virus be destroyed yes or no
because I it turns out that it's not
just a vial of smallpox actually a
collection of about 200 different
strains that have been isolated from all
over the world with different
pathogenicity 'z they've never been
sequenced so it's really a resource so
with that in mind I put up this and so
far I think there are 375 people who
have answered and most of them are
saying not to destroy the virus stocks
what would you say Saul yes or no
no no yes or no that's what you have to
answer the Pope you're not destroyed
problem is you're virologist and I am
and most of the people go to this server
I are interested in viruses so they're
more likely to say no so anyway I think
it's a resource in fact if he's right if
every wait say WH o said destroy them my
feeling is the US and Russia would say
sure and then they would never do it and
then you would have hidden stocks which
are even harder to police than public
one so I say leave them there and the
safe or wherever it is that they are and
maybe someday they'll be useful polio
was on the track to be eradicated whu-oh
has made a resolution to eradicate in
1988 they thought we would be done by
2000 and they wanted to stop immunizing
now we're were in 2011 now and we still
have polio globally the problem is that
polio reverts to a form that causes
polio whereas smallpox of actually never
reverts to cause smallpox and we know
that there are these vaccine derived
polio viruses all over the world so the
w-h-o has said if we ever eradicate
polio we're gonna stop immunizing
alright and the assumption is that once
you stop immunizing the live vaccine
goes away but that's turned out to be
incorrect but let me show you first the
effect of the polio eradication campaign
nineteen eighty eight about 400,000
cases globally and now two thousand
eight just in five countries among them
Nigeria India Pakistan and Afghanistan
and last year there were less than two
thousand cases so we've made a lot of
problem a lot of progress the problem is
that there are periodically outbreaks of
polio which are caused by the vaccine
and there have been recent ones in these
countries caused by circulating vaccine
derive I rescind
Western Hemisphere polio was eradicated
a number of years ago so immunization
becomes the levels become low countries
safe there's no polio globally why do I
have to immunize so then you have
pockets of susceptible individuals in
various places and then a vaccine
derived polio is introduced and it
causes
disease and so these are strains of
course that can spread in the population
and they can cause disease they're also
very interesting in immunocompromised
people who receive polio vaccine at two
months of age just like everyone else
and they can't clear it they shed it for
10-15 years or longer and they're fine
they're not sick at all so you don't
even know where they are and the number
of these individuals have been
responsible for sparking these outbreaks
of polio in these countries so basically
if you stopped immunizing one day you
would have a similar situation you would
have an increasing number of non immune
individuals and then the vaccine derived
viruses would eventually cause an
outbreak so you can't stop immunizing in
my view what do you have to do is you
have to basically vaccinate against the
vaccine so this is a paradoxical
situation now we've used an infectious
vaccine but it can cause disease that it
was meant to eradicate so when we're
done eradicating the disease we have to
then immunize with something else to get
rid of the vaccine so my view is to
start immunizing with the inactivated
vaccine and that's a problem because it
costs more and we don't know if it works
everywhere but then monitor the
environment and make sure the vaccine
derived polio viruses are gone before
you stop immunizing one day it's a
really interesting question because IPV
being expensive will probably just be
used in developed countries whereas the
underdeveloped nations which are
depending on w-h-o to buy them vaccine
as soon as no more OPV is available they
probably won't to immunize at all so I
suspect then under those conditions
there will be outbreaks again one day
for that reason we have to stockpile
polio there's still lots of polio and
research labs like my own there are
stored samples that have polio in them
but we don't know it and you can easily
make polio from the sequence it's only
seven thousand four hundred and forty
two bases in length and that's pretty
easy to have synthesize and make virus
from so you assume that you'll never be
able to get rid of all the sources of
polio so you have to stockpile some
vaccine and even if you are a
to eradicate polio one day as long as
you have the sequence you can make it
and you could do this for any virus of
course polio is easy because it's short
but even smallpox with a several hundred
thousand base pairs genome you could do
it as well so eradication is a concept
but in practice it really doesn't ever
happen
you